wir stellen mal wieder zufällig essen
heute gemeinsam mit dave wir sind hier
in unserem büro und es gibt sehr viele
neue restaurants die nicht zu mir nach
hause liefern dem entsprechen wird es
sehr spannend
wir werden als erstes zufällig eine
kategorie aus in der wird dann ein
restaurant suchen über das wir dann
essen bestellen die ganzen es gibt mal
wieder 69 kategorien es tut mir wirklich
leid wegen dem bohren aber es können wir
grade leider nicht ändern nennen wir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 69 46 11 an
kuchen jetzt sei aber müssen die süße ok
hat sich wieder bei denen ja auch franco
leute gibt es bei euch zu hause eine
pfannkuchen kategorie beliefern ich
glaube das ist einer der vorteile wenn
man in einer großstadt und wir haben ein
restaurant das ab ja das hat jetzt
restaurant sankt petersburg ein
russisches restaurant heißt das noch
übrigen nie bestellt ich auch nicht aber
das erübrigt uns wenigstens jetzt weiter
mit serie sprechen zu müssen und damit
dessen direkt was uns erwartet fünf von
fünf aus 3100 oh mein gott das sind
bestimmt alles echte bewertungen wie wir
uns von separaten hat er war
geisteskrank fünf sterne mit so vielen
bewertungen pelmeni ihr könnt ihr wenig
die hab ich ja schon bei persönlicher
koch übels geil wir zählen die
kategorien beliebte gerichte wie immer
außen vor
sagen eine zahl zwischen 1 und 11 8
bisher
das wäre am 9 saucen dann guck mal was
auch immer sagt mir eine zeit zwischen 1
und 3 scharfe tomaten okay mein favourit
von jana wieder besser werden dre du dir
erstmal ein hauptgericht und dann gucken
wir weiter
nennen wir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 11 8
auch mit für dich recht nennen wir eine
zeit zwischen 1 und 3
okay man dürfe saucen sind schon mal
gesichert leute dann gucken jetzt auch
wir auch noch etwas richtiges essen
dürfen aber stand eigentlich gut so wenn
so kriminelle oder sogar ins und wie er
genau wenn so was kommt ist stabil dann
bin ich wieder dran sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 11 3 okay okay wir haben
fleischgerichte nah ist glaube ich in
der russischen küche übelste nominiert
in der kategorie schlager bis richtig
safe glaub ich oh mein gott linie auch
übel ist geil das sind nämlich die
pfannkuchen geil digger dadurch übels
bock drauf übrigens wenn euch das video
gefällt lässt mag es gerne leichter das
hilft max und mir natürlich auch weil
ich mir geht's gut wenn s max gut geht
und wir können die miete bezahlen wenn
ihr like da das bei abo können wir sogar
gut leben ohne zu hungern also unbedingt
abonnieren 19 verschiedene gerichte sagt
mir eine zeit zwischen 1 und 9 10 4 14
14 liegt auf japanische art ist glaube
ich das premium gerichtlichen beilage
will ich mir jetzt einfach mal frei aus
bahncard offenheit als 17 euro das muss
aber wirklichkeit sein es kann bei mir
nur bergab
ja das schon so sehr wie nie wird es
glaube ich sogar bevorzugt weil das
kenne nicht alle nehmen eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 11 ok kategorie 55
vegetarische gerichte jetzt mehr bock
auf was mit mir hätte definitiv mehr
brocken fleisch gehabt aber vielleicht
gab es mal bei mir probieren hotel zum
thema acht verschiedene gerichte nehmen
wir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 8 soja
geschnetzeltes mit gegrillter paprika
zwiebeln springs tomatensoße frischen
koriander und waage nach wahl ist
eigentlich ein sehr exotisch beilage ich
nehme auch bereit hoffentlich geht es
kommt alles klar ich würde sagen kommen
dann mache für fand drehen wir noch was
dazu geht einfach mal in dieser
kategorie lag jedoch genau das kind auf
mein gott torte vogels splittert oft ja
die habe ich glaube die die russische
küche hat indes auch einiges zu bieten
auf jeden fall jeder ein bisher sagt mir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 11
ihr euch mit irgendwas so glücklich in
meinem haus
noch wird gleichzeitig das video immer
mit dave freeman nennen wir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 11
nice guy schokoladentorte das was man
was ich nach dem vegetarischen gericht
ja auch um mich so umzuhauen danach und
wir noch scharfe tomatensoße entspannt
so ganz vergessen 41 eur 50 ich bestelle
wir sehen uns gleich wieder ich hoffe
dass ich dann aufhöre zu bauen ja ja ja
das geht
klopp wir sagen halbe stunde 13 stunden
8 stunden 40 minuten schaffen mit
lammbraten delhi mit bratkartoffeln
schokolade eis splitterte und das
wichtigste schafe tomatensoße ich
marcell jansen doppelpack geschafft du
machtlos
lasst uns das alles mal auspacken und
anschauen und er hat nämlich dass bauern
auch ausgleich gebettelt
videoschnitt nicht entschuldige mich
vielmals aber er hat gefühl zum beispiel
an bord oder direkt auf ok wow
die bratkartoffeln sind damit ja ja und
das geht auch so ein bisschen spicy aus
was ja mehr genau was mir gut gefällt
das könnte sehr sehr gut firma eine tüte
viertel
lasst uns bitte schnell machen ich muss
es rein speisen so ich bin sehr gespannt
wie das wird aus 17 euro ist schon habe
ich ja schon habe ich hier beliefert das
essen aber und das sieht aber auch er
wie wichtig dass die soße dazu bestellen
na dann der würde ich sagen lasst uns
mal loslegen gute beide erstmal die
kartoffeln vom ihr mehr
ich habe mich immer gut auf jeden fall
schon mutig gekürzt aus was ich immer
gut finde ja top-speed aber eine kleine
konsistenz zu ihrem bisher war das war
ich habe den richtigen mix
ja ich hätte auch alles zu bestellen das
dachte ich nicht dass es so aussehen
würde und weil sie so sieht auch noch
durch gut oder hat er auch gleich drin
ja es ist ja mit soja getöteten genau
hergestellt mit der scharfen dose die
ich ihnen euro wert auf jeden fall und
dann probiert man ihre
betriebswirtschaftlichen kenne ich um
ehrlich zu sein er so aus der aus der
orientalischen küche aber ich bin sehr
gespannt
sehr lecker das würde ich ihnen dazu
geben also ich würde glaube ich meine zu
finden auch zwischen achteinhalb von 10
unser neuer glaube meint ist nur acht
weil sieht super aus aber etwas fehlt er
kriegt verstehen so dabei an sich sehr
sehr nah ist man aber dem problem fertig
wird ist aber bei unserem glück nur
sachen liebt man ohne so ein video
niemals gestellt also es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich fast eine süße und das
ist cool aber bin davon ausgegangen dass
ich auch als ich es auch gemacht habe
dass halt richtig sowieso eine suppe
genauso eine explosion wird aber sehr
positiv überrascht auf jeden fall aber
ich muss schon sagen dass ich jetzt
nicht das 50 aber sie 17 euro für zwei
spiele und eine handvoll bratfett sind
jetzt schon drauf hab ich noch nicht
sagen
sie dürfte es auf kosten vom feinsten
schlägt jetzt kommt das worauf ich dass
beide schon die ganze zeit warten dass
mich zurecht bisschen zurückgehalten wir
haben hier unsere schokoladen torte
unsere standorte und wir eröffnen das
ganze erstmal built for erwartet und
nicht sagen 5 50 kostet der bund auf und
genau so müssen also dann
hier sind unsere jeweiligen tortenstücke
also würde ich jetzt eigentlich aktuell
eher nicht reingehen aber die masse
alter sogar so ein bisschen cherry
merkt man merkt schon dass das ist wenn
man nur mit der gabel weiter damit damit
also gut der geschmack überrascht mich
irgendwie hast du diese von so so von so
wackeln
bist du dir sowas lese es ist gefühlt
sehr wenig was du im mund hat wenn du so
eine dame ist muss auf jeden fall
probieren also ich muss sagen bei mir
hat es mich überhaupt nicht überrascht
das aber nichts schlechtes sondern die
schmeckt einfach wie die aussieht
persönlich verrückt dieses ding
probierst du probiert man also jedes
mädchen zu mir gefällt darum ist die
waffel nämlich gar nicht so schwer wie
nun denkt genauso schwerwiegend und
genau das wäre wie man denkt aber nicht
so heftig wie man also mir gefällt die
nld ist und welcher muss ich sagen ich
glaube ich bin eher auf der spur aber ja
leute also das kriegt von mir einfach
weil ich noch nicht kannte auch einfach
achteinhalb zum 10
und wirklich sehr positive
überraschungen und ganzen großen wir uns
weiter auf jeden fall interessant
erfahren gewesen und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns am sonntag um 14 uhr wenn zeit
einen tag persönlicher koch für